bitcoin is the strongest asset the human
race has ever invented it's like gold
with none of the defects of gold
bitcoin's the first property
right independent
of the monopoly on violence
or independent of
uh physical protection production when
you look at bitcoin specifically
it has a financial component that is
unavailable in other assets it is
systematically built
to continue to protect your purchasing
power wanna be happy build a life not
just a business hey it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get a
master class in crypto investing enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one invest in volatile assets with
michael saylor so what's bitcoin well
bitcoin is the strongest asset the human
race has ever invented it's like gold
with none of the defects of gold so
define what the defects are why why is
it the greatest
monetary invention
so i buy uh a million dollars of gold
okay um
if the price goes up the gold miners
first of all the gold miner is going to
create more gold and dump it on the
market
if i could eliminate uh all gold mining
forever if i could wave a magic wand and
make it impossible to mine anymore gold
my million dollars a goal will hold its
value better because it'll be scarce
but gold miners are inflating the value
of the supply of gold by at least two
percent a year or so
and then if the price doubles again
investors will invest in more gold
miners and they'll create more capacity
to mine coal so you'll create capacity
to mine gold you'll mine the gold you'll
crank up the rate at which the gold
mines function
after that people with gold jewelry will
melt their jewelry down convert to gold
bullion and sell it right if the price
of gold went up by a factor of 20 you
would be like converting all your gold
stuff into gold bullion because it seems
like a good idea
they call it scrap gold right
and then after that um bankers will
issue gold warrants and gold and gold
paper and gold derivatives and they'll
sell them short without the gold because
they can speculate in it and they don't
have to have a one for one coverage of
gold to the gold derivatives
and so that's called hypothecation and
rehypothecation
okay if it keeps going up the
government's holding gold will start to
sell some of their gold to manipulate
the price down
right and all of these
and if and ultimately if it goes up
enough someone will club you over the
head and take your gold or a hostile
regime will take your gold
or a politician will pass a law taxing
your gold
right there's there's a lot of ways you
lose gold because it's physical
how do you cure the problem
right i mean
here's how you cure the problem you make
it impossible to mine any more gold and
then you make it possible to take
custody of your gold personally off of
the exchange or off of the bank
so that way the bank can't hypothecate
it or re-hypothecate it miners can't
inflate it investors can't create any
more gold miners and then you make it
possible to move it from here to
switzerland or singapore in an hour for
for a nickel
and that way if you don't like your bank
or don't trust your bank
if the state of new york passes a law
taxing it you move it to state of
wyoming
you know if the government passes the
law taxing you know the the ownership of
uh land in california you can't move the
land out of california can you
if you have a million dollars of gold in
a bank and in a vault in new york city
you know there's only a couple places
you can move it you can move it to
london if you have six months
okay so you're going to be subject to
the law of london or the law of
new york can you actually move to your
favorite island or you know can you move
to the cayman islands and bury your gold
underneath your hut in the cayman
islands and be safe about it
not likely
can't even get it through the airport
right so so the problem with other
properties and
gold is the simplest example but the
problem the the challenge or the analogy
holds with any property bitcoin
represents the apex property rights of
the human race
like i'm not mind you i'm not disputing
the ability or or the you know
legitimacy of a government to pass the
tax at the end of the day they can tax
your gold they can tax your stocks your
bonds your building yourself your income
whatever they want
but the point really is
you're a lot more likely to tax the
stuff that you walk past
you know every day on the way to work
and your lot
and
legitimately
you can move yourself
and you can move your property if it's
crypto to another jurisdiction but you
can't legitimately move a ranch in
california
so
your property rights are stronger and
the value of the property is higher
right you have a valuable thing in
manhattan it's interesting to other
wealthy people in manhattan but when you
have bitcoin it's interesting to wealthy
people everywhere on earth
right it's you can liquidate a billion
dollars of bitcoin on the weekend in any
currency
you know any any time
try liquidating a billion dollar
building
right that's three year process right so
it's liquid it's fungible it's desirable
and so that what that's what makes the
asset valuable and it's very it's the
it's the most difficult thing to impair
rule number two look for inviolable
property with robert breedlove we've
historically always needed an enforcer
so you need the police force you need
the military to make sure no one comes
into your house and violates your
relationship with your house
we needed
if maybe not necessarily a monopoly on
violence but you needed a protection
producing enterprise which historically
is the role of government to enshrine
your property rights
the problem of course is that they
willed the power to violate your
property rights as well which
historically has been very tempting for
governments and bureaucrats they
typically give into it and governments
get overthrown over time that's been the
cycle we're locked into
bitcoin's a first property
right independent
of the monopoly on violence or
independent of uh physical protection
production
it's an informational property right
it's just an alphanumeric string you can
store it in any information bearing
medium put in your mind put on your
computer put it in a song do whatever
you want with it
and there's no the enforcement is done
by the mining network so the algorithm
and the
free market competition that's going
into bitcoin mining is effectively
displacing
the protection that government was
historically necessary to provide in
bitcoin itself
so
it's this radical new you know some
people call it a metaphysical property
right and that it's just
an information bearer asset so gold was
really good as a bearer asset in that
you know assets equal liabilities plus
equity the accounting equation
gold was pure equity if i hold gold it's
no one else's liability that's really
important right i have no counterparty
risk if i hold physical gold
if i hold dollars that's not true right
i have this liability to the federal
reserve to the bank whoever whatever
counterparties are involved
bitcoins the same
as physical gold but it's non-physical
right it's informational
so it opens up this entire new
sphere of possibilities and how you
custody it you can custody bitcoin in
these multi-signature schemas that are
all but immune to theft
you can chop the key into a bunch of
pieces and distribute it geographically
you have these military-grade protocols
wrapped around it
and it gives you
an absolute it
it is the highest
implementation
of human self-ownership we've ever had
right in the past it's been scribbles on
the american constitution or the magna
carta and like we'll always
adhere to this document no matter what
but then you know a few hundred years go
by i'm like well you know let's tweak
this or change that or add this
bitcoin's taken those principles we've
used with foundational documents
historically and it's permanently
emblazoned them in computer code
in unbreakable code basically is another
way to think about it so
it's the
invention of inviolable property right
it's no longer a principle we've grabbed
this principle out of
the space of ideas and we've anchored it
into reality
via the thermodynamic competition of
bitcoin mining
and it is so
radically new and hard to get your head
around that it's shattering world views
worldwide rule number three embrace
technology with raul paul you start with
understanding money
which most of us don't think about then
you kind of understand how we're getting
screwed by central bank printing
and the debt-laden economy and what it
means
and then you start saying okay but
that's bitcoin and then what's this
ethereum business
and then you start realizing
decentralized finance you're like it's
kind of a finance thing but that's kind
of cool because i can get yields now you
know i can get instead of getting zero
on my bank account for my hard savings i
can now get six percent a year wow
that's a difference it's like going back
25 years in time
and then suddenly nfts come
and community tokens
and suddenly your mind is completely
blown that this is not just money it's
the entire exchange
transfer and storage of value
for the internet
whole business models are about to
change
massively because of what this
technology
unlocks and then once you get your head
around that you're like oh god i can't
even hold this in my mind any longer
it's so big um and that it's not just
buy some bitcoin i'm gonna make some
money over time
you know it's actually an entirely
parallel financial system
and business structure
for the world and it's being adopted
faster than anything we can ever imagine
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four buy when prices
are low with kathy wood you at one point
i think back in april told dow jones
that it could go to about
500 000 do you still hold that target do
you still think that's where we're
headed
i i we do i do yasin el mandra is our uh
crypto analyst and and uh we we go
through soul searching times like this
and and scrape the models and yes our
conviction is as high the one thing that
has changed here however
is the environmental concerns around uh
bitcoin in particular
have uh caused uh people like elon musk
to pull away and say whoa whoa whoa
let me let me make sure i understand
this
and uh we believe that even this is
going to change because first of all
right now
uh the percentage of bitcoin mined with
renewables and hydroelectric power
is quite substantial i think in uh china
it's over 50
in renewables
and we also believe uh and we wrote a
paper uh in conjunction with square on
this and we're going to have a
conference about it in july
we believe that bitcoin mining
integrated into the distributed grid and
by that i mean
solar roofs
power walls in homes
utilities merchant power producers uh
starting to include bitcoin mining in
the ecosystem why would they do that
they would do it because renewables are
intermittent power sources right
weather is it sunny or not wind is it
windy or not and bitcoin mining could
take off if it's if there's excess
energy
from solar being loaded into power walls
it can be offloaded into bitcoin mining
and the whole ecosystem therefore
becomes much more economic if this
happens we believe that the the uh
adoption of solar is going to accelerate
dramatically because there's another
profit center associated with it bitcoin
mining well
what happens though in the meantime so
here we are at 35 000 kathy do you think
we go much lower from here
uh you never know how low is low when a
market gets very emotional a lot of
traders see bitcoin
dropping below the 200-day moving
average
which is which was at 40 000.
so traders once that happen they just
dump some just uh dump and run
i think we're in a capitulation phase uh
yasin has a dashboard we were looking at
all the indicators this morning they are
all suggesting that we are in the
capitulation phase which is a really
great time
to
buy
no matter what the asset is a
capitulation phase is
buy it's on sale now
am i saying 35 000 is the low you know
if traders and there are a lot of
speculators in in bitcoin if they are
uh running for the hills just because uh
bitcoin has broken through a moving
average that is important to them it
could continue but all of our indicators
are saying this is capitulation right
now rule number five protect your
purchasing power with anthony pompliano
the purchasing power increases versus
the purchasing power of the dollar
decreasing and ultimately what i think
ends up being really important for the
conversation is there's a financial
component which we're talking about now
right is uh i want to store the value
of my time right and i think this is
like a really really key component of
the financial conversation is
all money is at the end of the day is a
unit of time and this is kind of a crazy
concept until you think about
why do you receive money
because you or somebody you employ or an
asset you built or some thing
is exchanging time for money
and so ultimately if you have lots of
money you end up having leverage on your
time if you don't have lots of money you
have to spend time to get dollars and so
money is just a unit of time and so when
i think about that
if i expend let's say an hour of work
today and i get paid 10 an hour and then
you tell me that i took that unit of
time i put in my bank account and then
in the future i would have to work two
hours to get that same ten dollars
well that actually doesn't feel that
great right in terms of it it feels like
i'm i can't keep up i've got i only have
so much time in a day and i'm constantly
falling behind but if instead you said
to me hey if you work an hour you get
ten dollars and then you put that money
in a form of an asset that is only going
to appreciate its purchasing power then
wait a minute in the future i actually
don't have to go work
for three or four hours because now i
have that ten dollars that saved from
the time i originally spent and so this
idea of like a unit of time becomes
really fascinating because what do rich
people understand
don't get in the game of trading your
personal time directly for hours right
they either employ other people or they
own assets that deliver them some sort
of financial return and so when you look
at bitcoin specifically
it has a financial component that is
unavailable in other assets it is
systematically built
to continue to protect your purchasing
power and protect could also just be
going sideways right just it doesn't
degrade it happens to be going up a lot
now because it's being repriced by the
world but at some point it'll reach some
stable value and it'll kind of just go
sideways and it'll protect that
purchasing power really important
concept rule number six be patient with
gary vaynerchuk 99 of the browsers and
search engines
that people made lots of money on in
valuation
in the mid 90s went out of business
i think it's very important for people
in this space to understand that it is
likely that 90 to 98
of the currencies will not make it
and so
there's always moments in time where
there's and what's so incredible about
this space is there's liquidation along
the way unlike when i was investing in
early stage startups you invested
and it was either feast or famine there
was no liquidation along the way which
is what has attracted a lot of the
behavior in this space but i please
i need people to understand to me
blockchain as a technology is a foregone
conclusion
but the currencies that are built on top
of that have enormous volatility for all
the people here that like to tell each
other how they made a million bucks in
12 months from zero
i want everybody know this is just my
real life i have over 10 000 direct
messages and emails in my inbox right
now
of people who maxed all their credit
cards and bought bitcoin at 15 000
right who are in deep
who are in massive depression
and sadness so please understand that
we're when we're in these spaces there's
enormous volatility
and it's very
early
like real early
like real
early
and i think that the lack of patience of
proving you were right or needing to
make
10 million bucks or whatever is going
through your mind
is the vulnerability the lack of
patience in this collective all of us
here together all the fancy people in
the back and all the people here our
collective vulnerability is lack of
patience
and so
i genuinely believe that if you're one
of the two or three people here who can
fundamentally change your path from the
quick score
because of the gold rush nature of the
oxygen in the room
to do you actually believe
in blockchain
do you believe in decentralization and
start being meaningful i believed
in social media in 2006
there was a lot of people who came and
went in 2006 7 8 9 10 who had a lot of
twitter followers there's a substantial
reason that i was able to see it all the
way through and be in the space with the
longevity because my behavior wasn't
helter skelter
it wasn't my pants weren't on fire
because i thought this social media
thing would be gone tomorrow i am
completely convinced and this is not a
disrespectful comment i'm completely
convinced that more than half this room
thinks that it's a quick score game and
have no sense or even are educated
enough to understand how this all plays
out
and i think within that is your
opportunity because i will say this
for the group that's here
you have such a substantial advantage
over 99 of people because you understand
this is actually even happening
the 99 of the people in the world
understanding of blockchain or crypto is
the word bitcoin and that's where it
starts and ends 99 in the collective 7.7
billion people please do not
underestimate
the ability of you being somewhere early
like you are and rule number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is look for adaptability with
robert kiyosaki bitcoin is not the only
crypto that you like you also like
ethereum
why do you like ethereum do you see
institutional investors getting into
ethereum as well as you correctly called
that they would be getting into bitcoin
no it's um michelle i'm an old guy you
know
trump and i are the same age
and i hang out with young guys and i ask
them questions about bitcoin and
ethereum
and there's so many there's so many
different crypt the reason i say
bitcoin is untested
because it is untested it's only been
around about 2009 or something
so that's why i'm very cautious with it
the same as all the other altcoins and i
think all coins are here to stay
but i don't know which one will survive
remember i know you're too young
when amazon came out so did pets.com
and people were buying pets.com and
pets.com disappeared
and amazon became the behemoth of the
world
so i didn't know anything about.com and
i don't know anything about crypto so i
talked to the young guys who are in it
every single day
and they kind of fill me up so they told
me to buy
uh i interviewed this guy robert
breedlove he said he's a cpa plus a
finance guy from wall street and all
this
and he is probably the most
knowledgeable on bitcoin in my personal
experience
and he's the one who's saying it's 1.2
million
so of all the people i trust him
then i asked him i said what happens if
somebody you know like let's say you and
i start our own uh coffee bitcoin
he says the beauty of bitcoin is it
adapts
so if this coffee bitcoin
starts kicking
bitcoins but
the bitcoin will adapt it's very similar
to amazon
amazon adapted it could morph it could
change
as new new uh
dot coms came online it could absorb
them
so that's why social media is so strong
today once they got a foothold
they could they could take over any
competitor they had
so they
the cryptocurrencies that everybody's
into cryptocurrency every young guy's
trying to start their own bitcoin now
but what this guy robert breedlith was
telling me
bitcoin will eat them alive
so i don't know if that's true or not
but being an old guy i gotta trust the
young guys that's all i'm saying
i have always seen myself as good at
making money and terrible at investing
money now you have to be very careful
what story you repeat about yourself to
yourself and i just kept saying that
like i'm i didn't want to focus on
learning about money math doesn't come
easily to me i don't like whatever that
ability is to conceptualize numbers i
don't have it so it's like i really
struggle with that stuff
and one of my employees was like tom are
you looking at crypto and i'm like david
i'm just not interested in investing
like it's not it doesn't speak to me at
all
and and he just kept coming back like
tom you really need to look at this you
need to look at this and i'm like david
how many times do i have to say like i
don't find this interesting i want to
build a company and i'll make yeah i've
already made myself wealthy i'll
continue to generate wealth and help
other people by building this company
i'm not going to look at it
and then
i had been introduced to the idea of
digital scarcity about six years ago
and i thought oh that's going to change
my business and then but the technology
wasn't there and so or i should say the
networks weren't there and i promptly
ignored it and then when it popped back
up at the beginning of 2021 i was like
i'm all in because i i understood what
it was going to be
so i start researching nfts the
technology behind it and that inevitably
leads you to the blockchain of course
which then leads you to crypto which
then i was like wait a second
what like this is literally
somebody is essentially going hey you
know all those things that make gold
like this wonderful store of value we're
now moving that onto computers and so
i've been saying for years technology is
a one-way street i'm a total like techno
optimist there is no going backwards
like this only moves forward so now it's
like
wait people are digitizing money and
then the poor david who'd been telling
me for god knows how eight months that i
needed to look at it i was like what the
hell so i start researching hardcore
about what it is and i'm like wow
not only do i have a
fiduciary responsibility to myself and
my family to learn about this
i now felt absolutely compelled to tell
people one simple thing
research it you may decide that it
doesn't make sense because i don't think
i'm smart enough for people to listen to
me i i do think that you're smart enough
for people to listen to you and you're
certainly educated
but even if they reject it like there
there is this moment of
you pull back the curtain and you see
the wizard of oz and you're like oh my
god this is going to change
everything and it's it's like a dime
drop on
how it works
and that's when i was like whoa i have
to move on this and i have to tell
everybody
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know what billionaires think
about bitcoin and if it's too late or
not check the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there i don't
worry
that uh you know his bitcoin will sort
of randomly go up or down
i do think people get bought into these
manias who may not have as much money